the 2022 World Cup is reshaping Qatar's
landscape in three years time this
country will host football's biggest
tournaments but already plans are being
made for what happens when it's all over
the man known in Qatar is dr. cool used
to design air-conditioning for cars for
the last decade he's been developing
cooling technology for football stadiums
science with long-term value for Qatar
and other countries aiming to combat
high temperatures the air goes out
gently towards the supporters then it's
recycled again like a conveyor belt this
is one of the things that makes the
technology sustainable we did not
air-conditioned the whole stadium but
target where the spectators are it's a
unique technology that Qatar introduced
to the world creating a meaningful
legacy is a complex challenge
particularly for a small country hosting
such a huge tournament the hosts have to
make sure that not only do the stadium's
have a life beyond 2022 but that
everything else that comes with a World
Cup also has a purpose before and after
the main event it means not just elite
teams are given access to the dozens of
new training pitches that have been
built they're also home to a community
league set up by World Cup organisers in
the world has access to world cup
training facilities in three years time
we're going to have the best footballers
in the world coming here and at this
moment in time for the next three years
and after 2022 our community Football
League with all of its players will be
playing on these facilities we all come
from different backgrounds we have
different careers and we come together
and this is what joins us this year
we've played on these pitches and I get
guests coming over from from home from
the UK and I'll bring them out here it's
going to have a look at the pictures
that we're going to to play on being
being part of this and the build-up to
the World Cup and it's amazing to be
here a grassroots football culture part
of the less visible legacy organisers
hope will be in place well beyond 2022
Andy Richardson al Jazeera Doha